well what we're gonna look at here is
the villa of the papyri it represents a
type of villa known as the villa
suburbano
that is a suburban villa and it's placed
just outside Herculaneum we have a nice
map which shows you what what this looks
like if you look at this plan what you
see is the city of Herculaneum oil the
town of Herculaneum on the right hand
side it's just about six blocks exposed
on the bottom part of the plan what you
see is in your regular outline of those
blocks that's how they wear in antiquity
because that irregular outline is the
Seacoast to the west just beyond those
blocks there is in fact a blank zone we
don't know what was there because it's
not been excavated but we think the city
wall was there just beyond that on the
left-hand side you see a building down
right on the Seacoast that is the villa
of the papyri here what we have is a
building with elements that mimic some
of the components of Roman townhouses it
has an atrium it has triclinium formal
Roman dining rooms this differs from
other Villa maritima such as the villa
of Tiberius it's pear longer which we
visit in another course of mind for the
teaching company experiencing Rome so
this is in fact different than then
every other Villa doesn't look like this
the villa is centered around the atrium
and it is extraordinary for its size now
I need to say something about the
excavation of the villa of the papyri
here the villa was excavated in the
1750s and so quite a long time ago and
it was excavated and initially by a
swiss mining engineer who was brought in
to tunnel down through the 60 feet of
solid rock which in fact makes up the
eruptive material that covered the villa
and so it was excavated with tunnels so
what we have is a floor plan of the
villa and excavation and a lot of
material from the villa which I am
certain does not represent the full
extent of it so what we have here
only preliminary measurements but if you
look at a plan of the villa what you see
is it's organized along the seafront
exposure and the major wing of the villa
is over 250 meters long and that if I've
done the math correctly is about 836
feet that's not the entire state
that's 836 feet just in the major wing
of the villa the villa is not just on
that main floor however it in fact is in
at least four storeys created on
terraces above the level of the seafront
and it consists of Suites of rooms of
ambulatory spaces along the sea formal
gardens baths installations really has a
tremendous range of rooms well if we
were here in 40 BC with Calpurnia's
Paizo the owner of the villa we might go
through a day out here there would be
something like this and I think it's to
be a good reconstruction of what's going
on elite Romans first off liked to walk
for exercise they like to stroll and so
they create these wonderful ambulatory
spaces long passage ways in which they
can just walk there's one of these here
at the villa along a portico overlooking
the sea so it's on the west frontage of
the villa now even enormous complex
lavish buildings like the villa of the
papyri in antiquity don't have any
climate control so what you do is you
move through the building seasonally and
depending on the time of the day so in
certain seasons you'd use certain rooms
and the summer certain rooms in the
winter and you can also do this during
the time of the day in the morning I
think what we see here is Paizo walking
along this portico just strolling along
the seafront because the prevailing
winds are from the west you get those
cool breezes and the bulk of this
four-story building is behind him on the
east so it's shading him from the Sun
and I think this is a marvelous idea you
can do this today I've done this my cell
phone bill is down on the Bay of Naples
and you get a marvelous sense of the
villas connection to the surrounding
landscape and to regional life down here
you